اهلا بكم مشاهدينا ملف جديد يطفو على سطح
الخلافات الداخليه في ايران التي لم تعد
القضايا السياسيه وحدها تثير الانقسامات
بين اجنحتها المعتدله او
المتشدده ملف الفساد واحد من الملفات
المسكوت عنها في زمن العقوبات لاعتبارات
المصالح الاقتصاديه يثير اليوم ازمه بين
راسي السلطتين التنفيذيه والقضائيه حسن
روحاني وصادق
لاريجاني عنوان الازمه حكم الاعدام الصادر
بحق احد ابرز رجال الاعمال مال في زمن
العقوبات وعلى عهد احمد نجاد لكن تفاصيلها
لا تخلو من مكونات السياسه واهدافها مزيد
من التفاصيل في التقرير
التالي تنشغل الساحه الايرانيه الداخليه
هذه الايام بالسجاد الحاصل بين السلطه
القضائيه ومؤسسه الرئاسه وملف السجال هو
احد اثقل واغرب واعقد ملفات الفساد الكبرى
في البلاد والمعروف بملف بابك زنجاني
زنجاني هذا المحكوم عليه اليوم بالاعدام
هو نفسه بطل مرحله العقوبات زمن الرئيس
السابق احمد نجاد يومها قام الرجل وبتشجيع
من جهات رسميه بالالتفاف على العقوبات
الدوليه الاوروبيه المفروضه على البلاد
على خلفيه البرنامج النووي ول ثماني سنوات
كانت الاولويه لكسر شوكه العقوبات على
حساب الشفافيه ويومها كان زنجاني رجل
الاسواق السوداء ومنقذ الاقتصاد الوطني من
الانهيار سلم ملف زنجاني للقضاء الذي حكم
عليه بالاعدام بمجرد اعدام الرجل يعني ان
الملف سيغلق نهائيا وستطوى معه تفاصيل
مهمه ربما لو فتحت لجرت معها مسؤولين
اخرين الى ساحات المحاكمه انتقد الرئيس
روحاني حكم الاعدام وطالب باليات امنيه
وقضائيه لاسترجاع الاموال المنهوبه
والمهرب الى خارج البلاد رد القضاء بانه
يتوجب على الرئيس الاهتمام بحل مشاكل
البطاله والفقر والادمان التي تعتبر اهم
اسباب استشراء الفساد في المجتمع بعيدا عن
استجال في قضيه زنجاني يعتبر الفساد
الاقتصادي ملف دائم الحضور على طاوله كل
الرؤساء والحكومات في ايران وتعود جذوره
الى مرحله ما بعد الحرب العراقيه
الايرانيه التي عرفت بمرحله البناء زمن
الرئيس الاسبق هاشمي رفسنجاني يومها تمت
خصخصه الاقتصاد وفتحت الاس واق على
الاقتصاد الحر ووقعت العقود مع الشركات
العابره للقارات بهدف اعاده بناء البلاد
وانعاش اقتصادها كل ذلك جرى دون اليه
حقيقيه للمحاسبه والرقابه وهكذا بات
الفساد والفاسدون جزءا من اقتصاد البلاد
في مرحله ما بعد الحرب مع قدوم الرئيس
احمد نجاد الى السلطه واشتداد العقوبات
التي ضيقت الخناق بشكل كبير على الاقتصاد
عرفت البلاد ملفات في الصحافه باتت تعرف
باضخم قضايا الفساد والاختلاس في تاريخ
ايران والسبب ان الاولويه يومها كانت
للالتفاف على العقوبات وليس للشفافيه
والمحاسبه بات الامر اكثر خطوره عندما
بدات بعض الجهات السياسيه في ايران تسيس
ملفات الفساد لصالح تحقيق مكاسب سياسيه
والساحه الايرانيه تعج باكثر من مثال ليس
هذا فقط بل ان العدوى انتقلت الى السياسات
الخارجيه فاليوم تطالب ايران كندا باعاده
تسليمها مدير البنك الوطني محمود رضا خوري
الذي فر بعد اتهامه باكبر عمليه اختلاس
عرفتها ايران وذلك كشرط لاعاده العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين البلدين اليوم وبامر
مباشر من المرشد الاعلى تخوض حكومه روحاني
واجهزه البلاد الامنيه والقضائيه اكبر
عمليه ضد الفساد الاقتصادي وتحاول القضاء
على هذه الافه التي تنخر جسد الاقتصاد ومع
كل ملف تطفو تفاصيله على السطح يكتشف حجم
ورط مسؤولين حاليين واخرين سابقين في
ملفات فساد كبرى حتى وصل الامر الى الحديث
عن مدى تمكن الفساد من المؤسسه العسكريه
التي لا تزال بعيده عن المحاسبه في ملفات
كهذه وينضم الينا من طهران الباحث المتخصص
في القضايا الايرانيه محمد حسين انصاري
فرد وفي الاستديو تنضم الينا الخبيره في
الشؤون الايرانيه فاطمه امادي معك ابدا
سيد محمد حسين انصاري لفرد والسؤال يعني
الذي يطرح نفسه لماذا تم الانقلاب على
بابك زنجاني الذي كان محميا من احمدي نجاد
وحتى ايضا حتى الامس القريب يعني كان
مقبولا او حتى محميا من الرئيس حسن روحاني
فضلا عن الحرس
الثوري اعتقد ان السيد زنجاني
لم لم يخلق في يوم واحد بل هو كان نشطا في
النشاط وفي الاوساط الماليه لاكثر من 20
سنه منذ زمن زان جني وخاتمي واحمدي نجاد
والان اثناء فتره ولايه روحاني وقد اتهم
بالفساد وهو يقول بانه لم يقم باي اعمال
فساد بل ما قمت به قال هو اني
بعت
بعض المنتجات البترو كيمياويه
وعندما اردت ان استعيد اموالي العقوبات
منعتني من ذلك ذلك ان كل اموالي قد حجزت
في دول اخرى وخاصه في الدول الغربيه
وبالتالي انا حاولت ان استعيد هذه الاموال
الى واعيدها الى بلادي وكن لم اقم باي
عمليه فساد ولكن المشكله هي ان السيد
زنجاني له
صور
و
و تصريحات من مختلف الرؤساء والوزراء
والمسؤولين تقولون انه يقول انه في الماضي
كان رجل اقتصادي مالي كبير ومهم وهو لم
يكن يعمل لوحده بل كان لديه حاشيه تحيط به
وكان يعمل بنظام من الوطني من البرمجه
الوطنيه وبالتالي فالموضوع في الواقع معقد
سيدي محمد سيدي محمد حسين عفوا عفوا سيدي
محمد حسين اي يعني حتى نختصر الوقت وناخذ
معلومات اكثر حول هذه النقطه سالتك نعم
هذه التفاصيل كلها اصبحت معروفه وا يحكى
فيها داخل الوسط الايراني لكن السؤال شخص
كان محمي بهذه الطريقه وكان في لحظه معينه
عماد الاقتصاد الايراني اثناء العقوبات
وكل الشوائب التي حكي عنها كانت معروفه من
قبل كل المسؤولين الايرانيين السؤال لماذا
وضع الان تحت الضوء وحكم بالاعدام وحده
دون غيره من الحاشيه التي اشرت اليها انت
اريد اجابه مختصره
ارجوك اتق ان ان هناك تنافس سياسي هو الذي
اثر على هذا الموضوع فكنا نقترب من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه بعد بضعه اشهر وعليه
هناك متنافسان
احدهم احدهم اصلاحي والاخر غير اصلاحي
وبالتالي اعتقد السيد روحاني بحاجه الى
تقديم بعض الاجوبه على الاسئله يطرحها
الاصلاحيين وخاصه من جيل الشباب حول ما
قام به حول كل الوعود التي قدمها في
المنتخبات الماضيه اذا انه قال انه سيقوم
باتخاذ اجراءات ضد بعض المور القضايا بما
في ذلك مكافحه الفساد وان نجد ان الجانبين
يلقين اللوم على الطرف الاخر وبالتالي
اعتقد ان هذه المنافسه ستستمر الى ان يحين
موعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه بل انها تزدان
سخونه وشده في الاشهر القادمه الى عين
موعد الانتخابات طيب سيده فاطمه الموضوع
له علاقه بالانتخابات في جزء منه ولكن
السجال الذي حصل في ايران يدل على ان قضيه
بابي بابك زنجاني انما هي فقط اي راس جبل
الجليد اذا صح التعبير يعني عندما السلطه
القضائيه تتهم الحكومه بشوائب في حساباتها
الماليه
فالحكومة ترد السلطه القضائيه بانها لا
تريد ان تكشف الاسماء من اجل حرمه بعض
الشخصيات هذا يعني بان الامر كبير جدا على
مستوى الفساد نعم ملف الفساد في ايران هو
واحد من ملفات الصراع السياسي في ايران
يظهر عندما يكون هناك حاجه ل له في هذا
الصراع يعني اعيد الى الاذهان في 2009 في
الانتخابات ال الرئاسيه كان ملف الفساد
واحدا من ابرز الموضوعات في المناظرات
الانتخابيه احمدي نجاد وجه اتهام مباشر
وصريح لراب سنجاني وعائلته بانهم ضالعون
في الفساد في ايران ايضا قبل ذلك بعام في
2008 هناك يعني تسريبات مشهوره جدا في
ايران هي تسريبات عباس بالزاد اي هذه هذه
التسريبات من رجل خرجت من رجل كان يعمل
محاسب لدى المحكمه العليا يعني وايضا كان
في مركز الابحاث التابع لمجلس الشورى هذا
الرجل كشف عن ما يزيد عن 100 ملف فيها ما
يزيد عن 30 شخصيه مهمه في ايران ضالعا في
الفساد من ضمنها 11 شخصيه من ابرز رجال
الدين في ايران منهم كان وعد طبسي الذي
توفي في السنه الماضيه وكان ساد للعتبات
المقدسه في في مشهد واثير قضيه قضيه كبيره
حول هذه المساله واحمد وكان هذا الرجل من
المقربين من احمد نجاد
ووعد يعني كان احمد نجاد يتامل ان يقدم
الى القضاء كل هؤلاء لكن في المحصله تمت
محاكمه عباس بيزات وتهم بان باثاره باثاره
الفتنه داخل ايران وتعريض الامن القومي
للخطر وتسريب معلومات سريه ما اردت ان
اقوله انه ليس موضوع جديد لكنه يظهر بشكل
كبير جدا في التنافس والصراع السياسي حتى
احمد نجاد نفسه اتهم في في الفساد ب من
خلال فريقه واتهم هو عائله كل هذه
الاتهامات يعني وصلت الى حد انه احمد
خاتمي عضو مجلس الخبراء وخطيب جمعه يقول
ان هذه الاتهامات تهدد الوحده الوطنيه
ودعى الى وقف كل هذا السجل وكل هذه
الاتهامات يعني السؤال اذا كانت السلطه
القضائيه بحد ذاتها متورطه ايضا في عمليه
الفساد كما يتهمها روحاني فضلا عن ان
السلطه التنفيذيه كذلك من الذي يحاسب هنا
يعني النفس نفس هذه القضيه اثيرت في 2009
وقيل ان احمد نجاد عندما وجه التهم
بالفساد للجميع فهو بذلك قد وضع علامه
سؤال كبرى على كل مجمل النظام الايراني
يعني اذا كان رموز النظام الايراني ضالعون
في الفساد فهذه مشكله كبرى وفي تلك وفي
ذلك العام اغلق ملف النقاش حول هذه القضيه
وقضايا اخرى بامر من المرشد حتى عندما جرى
يعني نقاش حاد بينم الارجاني في البرلمان
الايراني واحمد نجاد وايضا تم جرى اتهام
بالفساد ايضا اغلقت باوامر من من المرشد
لانه يقود الى تعزيز بؤره الصراع في بين
بين الفرقاء الان هذا هذا الملف ايضا
سيتعاظم لان الانتخابات اقتربت وروحاني
على وجه التحديد ايضا متهم بالفساد عندما
هو عندما اثار قضيه النشاط الاقتصادي
للحرس ك اتهم بالمقابل بان حسين فريدون
شقيق ايضا ضالع في الفساد ف الموضوع
الموضوع لا ينتهي في بموضوع الاتهامات
والاتهامات المتبادله اريد ان اشير هنا
هنا الى ان
الرئيس الايراني حسن روحاني قال في معرض
اتهامه لرئاسه السلطه القضائيه في بلاده
بالتستر على الحقيقه فيما يتعلق بملفات
الفساد قال روحاني ان الشعب يريد معرفه
الحقيقه فيما يتعلق بسر
ثلاثه مليارات دولار واضاف روحاني كيف
يعقل ان يسرق كل هذا المبلغ من قبل شخص
واحد دون مساعده من مؤسسات واشخاص مازالت
اسمائهم بعيده عن
التحقيق اعود الى ضيفي من طهران محمد حسين
انصاري فرد سيدي
محمد لماذا لا يتم الكشف برايك عن اسماء
المتورطين كما يطالب بذلك يا روحاني
ولماذا الاستعجال في تنفيذ حكم الاعدام
قبل ان يتم استدعاء شخصيات
اخرى قيل بان بابك زنجاني
قد اورد اسمائهم في معرض التحقيق في قضايا
الفساد
اعتقد ان السيد
روحاني
بقدر عرفنا و وبعد اغراب انتخابات يحتاج
ان يحصل على دعم من الجيل الجديد والشباب
والذي يحمل لديه اسئله كثيره فلو كان هناك
مشاكل اقتصاديه وهناك تفشل البطاله ونسبه
تضخم عاليه فلماذا كثير اشخط مثل هذا
الرجل مثل زنجاني لماذا يحصل على كل هذه
الاموال
من الفساد وان على السيد روحاني ان
يجيبهم بالقول ان هذا الرجل زنجاني ليس
رجلنا نحن فهو من رجال الماضي اي من فتره
الرئاسه السابقه واننا نحاول تحسين الامور
ومكافحه الارها الفساد ومن جانب اخر يقوم
بمهاجمه النظام
القضائي كنقطه اساسيه
ورئيسيه
مهاجمه
المعارضين الاصوليين وبالتالي نعتقد ان
هذه الخلافات والهجمات ستزداد في الاشهر
القادمه مع اختراب الانتخابات الرئاسيه
وبعد ذلك سوف تهدا من جديد ا هل هل حتى
تهدا الامور تتوقع ان يكون بابك زنجاني هو
كبش الفداء وبالتالي تطمس قضايا الفساد من
من جديد هل تتوقع
ذلك كلا لا اعتقد ذلك فاظن انه في نهايه
المطاف ان المرشد الاعلى سينصح الطرفين
بال بالهدوء وعدم اثاره الراي العام وعدم
الاضرار بالبلاد وعدم في بينهم واذا كان
لديهم اي اسئله وتساؤلات وخلافات فلابد ان
يحلوها ما وراء المسرح او مرا وليس
علنا دون اثاره الراي العام سيده فاطمه
سمادي القضيه خرجت الى الراي العام ايران
تشتعل بهذا الجدل في الوقت الحاضر سيكون
هناك دعوه للهدوء كما ذكرنا خاتمي احمد
خاتمي يقول لا ينبغي للقضاء اثاره ملفات
الفساد في الحكومه الحاليه او السابقه
ماذا يعني ذلك واين هو او كيف يمكن ان
يؤثر ذلك على الراي العام في نظرته الى
كلا الطرفين ا كان معتدلا او متشددا في
ايران لا اظن انها هذه قضيه تتراكم يعني
تشكل نقطه ضغط كبيره في المجتمع الايراني
خاصه مع ما اشار اليه الضيف الكريم بانه
معدل التضخم عاد للارتفاع يعني بعد ان وصل
الى 7% عاد الى
10% الريال قيمه الريال الايراني تتراجع
امام الدولار بشكل كبير اخر احصاءات ال
وزاره الرفاه تتحدث عن 30 مليون فقير في
ايران هذه ارقام ايرانيه يعني ليست ليست
من الخارج هناك ملايين الذين يعيشون في في
العشوائيات هناك نقاش داخلي ايراني حول
الفقر في الفتره الاخيره بصوره ضاغطه
وحقيقيه اي روحاني ايضا الان في وضع حرج
لانه وعد في برنامجه الانتخابي ب يعني
حلحل الامور الاقتصاديه وهو لم يستطع على
الرغم من انه انجز اتفاق نووي هذا الاتفاق
لم ينجح في حلحال الوضع الاقتصادي هناك
ايضا نسبه البطاله مرتفعه جدا في ايران
وبالتالي هذا الملف انا في ظني انه
سيتزايد طرحه وليس يعني ينتهي بصوره لانه
ربما لانه قريب من الانتخابات قريب من
الانتخابات وايضا ال الملف النووي او
الاتفاق النووي على وشك ان يدخل في ازمه
هذا سيتضح بشكل اكبر بعد مجيء ترامب يعني
توليه الرئاسه بصوره فعليه وبعد ان تتضح
ملامح توجهاته نحو ايران الانتخابات
القادمه ايضا يعني صعبه جدا انا في رايي
لكل الفرقاء في ايران وبالتالي سيتم
التركيز على هذا الملف بصوره اكبر لكن بعد
ما شاهدتي
واطلعت على هذا الجدل من راس السلطات
الاساسيه في ايران حتى يعني من الشخصيات
الاساسيه في الدوله تدعو الى طمس هذه
الملفات هل هناك فعلا من هو قادر على فتح
ملفات الفساد في ايران اكان الان او حتى
في المستقبل القريب بالنظر الى ما ادت
اليه هذه القضيه هذه المساله مرتبطه بشكل
اساسي بما يسمى في ايران اقتصاد الظل وهذا
وفق البنك المركزي يعني نسبته او معدل 20%
من الاقتصاد الايراني اقتصاد ظل في حين
بعض ال بعض الدراسات تقول انه من 40 الى
60% اقتصاد الظل مرتبط بشكل اساسي بنشاط
جهات عديده من ضمنها الحرس الثوري يعني
الحرس الثوري ايضا يعني رؤساء ايرانيين من
خاتمي الى احمدي نجاد الى روحاني حاولوا
ان يثيروا اسئله حول النشاط الاقتصادي
للحرس الثوري ال الغير يعني الغير خاضع
لرقابه الحكومه وفشل انا في ظني ان هذا
الملف يعني في جزء منه يتعلق بالنشاط
الاقتصادي للحرس وهنا تاتي حساسيته وعدم
قدره جهات كثيره على ان يعني تدخل فيه
بشكل كبير اها اشكرك جزيلا فاطمه صمادي
الخبيره في الشؤون الايرانيه واشكر من
طهران محمد حسين انصاري فرد الباحث
المتخصص في القضايا
الايرانيه احزاب اسلاميه جزائريه اعدت
العده للانتخابات التشريعيه القادمه ب
ماجات وتحالفات وبقيت محل قراءات وتقويما
متباينه عبد الصمد ناصر يسلط الضوء في
ملفنا الثالث لحصاد اليوم على الحراك الذي
يشهده البيت الاسلامي في الجزائر